-We don't always have enough
time to cover
everything in the news,
so here with a recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call,
"Amber Says What."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys,
things have been crazy!
Okay, so, first of all,
the Super Bowl was this weekend.
And I saw the halftime show
and I was like, "What?!"
Shakira played the drums,
Then J.Lo did some
crazy stuff on a pole,
and I was like, "What?"
Then someone reminded me
that J.Lo is 50,
and I was like,
"What kind of sorcery is this?"
Who are you?
Jen-jamin Buttons?"
Then I found out part of Trump's
border wall fell over,
and I was like, "What?"
And then I found out
it fell over onto Mexico,
and I was like, "Oh, what?!"
What did this? A bulldozer?
A wrecking ball?
No, the wind.
The wind blew it over.
And I was like, "What?"
Well, at least that
won't happen again,
because if there's one thing
that's super-rare
on planet Earth, it's wind.
P.S., of course the wall
got blown down.
The only thing propping
it up was racism.
[ Laughs ] Oh!
If you think about it,
yeah, that was...
Then, the National Science
Foundation's solar telescope
took its first picture
of the sun.
And I saw it
and was like, "What?"
From far away, the sun is
a beautiful hot ball of
glowing gases whose gravity
holds the solar system together.
But up close, the sun ain't
nothing but a big, old ashy leg.
Hey, astronauts, the next time
you go up there,
bring some lotion.
Then Beyoncé came out
with a new line of clothes.
And I was like, "What?!"
Then she sent her famous friends
giant boxes of the clothes.
And I was like, "What?!
That is so cool."
Hey, Seth, did you get a big old
box of clothes from Beyoncé?
-I think you know I did not.
-So then, soon after,
people started noticing how
the line of clothing
resembled uniforms at Popeyes.
And I looked at the similarities
and I was like,
"What...a coincidence!"
Then Popeyes came out with
its own line of clothing
that looks a lot like
Beyoncé's fashion line.
And I was like, "What?!"
Popeyes!
I'm a size medium.
Then presidential candidate
Michael Bloomberg
met a dog for what I guess
was the first time,
and this happened.
I was like, "What?!
Did this billionaire just try to
shake a dog's mouth?"
Have you never met a dog before?
Man, dogs are for petting.
Booties are for shaking.
Then a zoo in England
recently discovered
that their big cats
are more active
in their environment
if you spray
Calvin Klein's
Obsession for Men.
And I was like, "What?!"
That's not a surprise.
That cologne is from 1998.
Of course cougars love it.
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
Y'all have to stop.
You can't just be
"ohh-ing" everything.
"Cougars? Ohh!
Racism? Ohh!"
Then I read an article that said
Harry and Meghan's choice
to step back from
the royal family
was a missed opportunity to heal
race relations in the U.K.
And I was like, "What?!"
It is not her job to fix
your [bleep] country.
Besides, she already taught you
the most valuable
lesson of all --
black people don't have time
for your [bleep]
so treat us right
or we'll move to Canada!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I said, we will move to Canada!
Do you hear me, Seth?
-Sorry. What?
-That's what I thought!
Then something happened that you
are never going to believe.
Okay, for real, last week,
in a town called
Perryville, Maryland,
a white man robbed a bank
in blackface.
And I was like,
"What are you doing?!"
Now, you know there's probably
only one black person
in Perryville, Maryland,
and his life is bad enough.
But, on the bright side,
that bank robber
probably got home,
and his wife was like, "Ooh!
No, Bob. Leave it on."
Then, yeah, they had weird sex.
Then I heard my favorite person
to look at, Billy Porter,
was at the Grammys,
and I was like,
"What...did he wear?"
And I saw him,
and he looked beautiful.
Then I saw that he had a crazy
hat, and I was like, "What?!
It's gorgeous!"
Then I saw that it had an
internal mechanism
that opened and shut its
bedazzled veil,
and I was like, "What?!"
Look.
Man, I tell you what -- if I
ever got my hands on that hat,
we wouldn't be doing no
"Amber Says What."
We'd be doing "Billy Porter's
Hat Says What."
And guess what.
I did. And now we are.
It's time for "Billy Porter's
Hat Says What."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys,
things have been crazy.
First of all, I heard that
Gwyneth Paltrow
is selling a candle
that smells like her vagina.
And I was like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then Trump's campaign held
a rally to win over
black voters by handing out cash
in a black community.
And I was like...
"Where you doing that at?"
But then I found out the Black
Women's Caucus of South Carolina
endorsed Tom Steyer
for president.
And when I realized the closest
thing the Democratic Party
has to a black woman is
Tom Steyer, I was like...
This Has been "Amber Says What
in Billy Porter's Hat."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]